[Music]
yeah series finale here we are six
seasons later you know I thought to know
when you read that final script what was
your initial reaction I hate to say we
both cried we did it's the truth
separately we're in different places but
we both cried for various reasons for
what was on the page and what the last
page meant on and off the screen
you have any face time cheering crying
conversation no face time - oh yes yeah
no no face time thing it's just texts
I'm crying you yeah even the body count
on the Americans were you surprised that
both of your characters survived at the
final episode I know what was gonna
happen actually I had no idea what was
gonna happen I think it I agree I was I
kind of said to myself just for reading
out if one of us dies understandable if
we both make it a bonus fans are already
starting a Twitter campaign for Holly
saying that they want a page spinoff
series what are your thoughts on that
and the page actually you did turner
yeah yeah yeah a little bit betrayed
little envious to be honest why aren't
we getting a spinoff this country shall
be cold and we won't be yeah cuz if she
does this by show you should be out at
night yeah good luck to us she's young
not only were you to the leads of in my
opinion one of the best dramas in the
history of television but you found love
together you had a baby together looking
back how does that make you feel he's -
it's a nightmare
the Americans coming to a close is there
anything you're looking forward to do as
a family now that you have a little bit
more time together remind them who we
are
timing them lastly carry your career
started so early on the Mickey Mouse
Club have your kids seen any of those
old episodes they've seen like little
tiny clips we started showing them River
just thought it was stupid and Willow
was confused I understand what's going
on and when you showed some the Sesame
Street moment he is mind exploded so I
think that's the gamut of any actors
dream really they've been hitting you at
me in like uh you know Justin Timberlake
you know Ryan Gosling no don't think
we're cool at all they're kind of like
unless you're a professional basketball
player he said use it ISIF babysit
Britney Spears and who
[Music]
[Applause]